I saw you at All-Star game we shared a
very warm embrace I explained to you how
beautiful New York City is and how if
you come to New York City and you win
One World Series you will never pay for
food jewelry travel nothing everything
will be covered for Life trust me you
win one championship in New York City
and you are a guy you can go to the
Dodgers you can go to the Padres you can
go to the Mets but your name is not
going to ring off in the history of
baseball like it would if you were a
Yankee my brother let's be real with
yourself and also I'm here I live here
so we can hang out on weekends I got a
saltwater pool it's 12 foot deep on the
deep end you know what I mean I know
you're a tall guy you like to swim we
goodbye bro New York City is the place
for you so hey come through